why
so with agent Peggy Carter receiving her
own TV show in the near future I figured
it'd be a good idea to do a video about
Peggy Carter but because her publication
history is not very extensive I thought
it'd be a good idea to really kind of
beef up this video and add some meat and
potatoes to it by comparing and
contrasting Peggy Carter from the comic
books to Peggy Carter and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so Peggy Carter is
first presented to us in Captain America
comics issue number one in 1941 and
what's really kind of interesting here
and one thing I would like for you all
to take particular note of is that the
Peggy Carter character as she's
presented to us some Marvel Comics is in
a lot of ways vastly different than the
character and the way that she's
presented to us and Captain America the
First Avenger when Peggy Carter is first
introduced to us and Marvel Comics she's
simply referred to as x13 and this is
one of the interesting kind of ways that
Marvel has sort of I wouldn't go as far
as to say revamped her character but
kind of made an adjustment in terms of
how she's presented to us and the comics
she meets a group of individuals who are
heading to the location or to the
experimental area where the
super-soldier formula is going to be
commenced on Steve Rogers and we see
that she is undertaking the guise of an
old woman and greets the individuals and
once they pass the test so to speak to
prove that they are in fact supposed to
be there she ungai cz's herself and she
showed we see that she's a young woman
and this is actually the last time that
we will ever see Peggy Carter in the
Captain America original comics she
actually won't pop up again until tells
a suspense issue number 64 and again we
don't really know that she's Peggy
Carter we don't know what her name is
she simply referred to as agent 13 now
ultimately were given context to the
character although again we're not given
her name in tales of suspense issue
number 77 I believe and what we see here
is that Steve Rogers and Peggy Carter
are romantically involved with each
other and again I think this was an
extremely
telogen thing on behalf of marvel
because we don't really know how it was
they became romantically involved we
really kind of have this dead space
between the time that we saw her entails
a suspense issue number 64 and tales of
suspense issue number 77 and we don't
exactly know how much time took place
between these two comics now in terms of
her actual full-on appearance in terms
of her appearing and a modern day so to
speak and this actually doesn't happen
until Captain America issue number 161
and 162 and ultimately it's actually we
see her as who she is and we see her
identified as Peggy Carter and Captain
America issue number 162 and what we
learn is that in the flashback of tales
of suspense issue number 77 that when
she and Steve Rogers were romantically
involved that they had been separated
Steve Rogers had been called away on a
mission and while he was away on this
mission Peggy Carter was kidnapped by
the Gestapo and during a liberation of
the camp in which she was being held she
was exposed to a violent explosion which
caused amnesia and so between tales of
suspense issue number 77 and tales of
suspense issue number 162 her character
is really just kind of trying to figure
things out and really kind of trying to
understand what her place is over time
her memory slowly kind of begins to come
back in bits and pieces and she is aware
of who Steve Rogers is but she is told
that he was killed in 1945 as a result
she really kind of shuts down and she
kind of D evolves to the process of
wearing black all the time where she's
constantly mourning now what we see
towards the end and actually at the end
of Captain America issue number 162 is
that she's reunited with Steve Rogers
and the two of them escaped the base in
which she was being held now we
ultimately see that Peggy Carter's
character is killed or she dies and
Captain America vol 6 issue number one
and this is really kind of a big thing
here because it's really kind of I guess
places Captain America in a place where
he moves from the past and into the
present more so than he ever had before
and the reason why was because Peggy
Carter was really kind of a
last high that held him to the past that
held him to the original Captain America
Comics had held him to the World War 2
era of his life and with her passing he
was now able to really kind of move
forward into the present and become a
part of the present and walk away from
his past life so Peggy Carter doesn't
really have any abilities for the most
part she is your average normal human
being for the most part she has some spy
training she has some military training
as an American that fought with French
forces in World War two but aside from
that there really isn't much to her I
mean she knows how to shoot she knows
how to use guns she's pretty accurate
but there really isn't a whole lot of
her in terms of her overall prowess and
her capabilities of course she's agile
and she has great hand-to-hand combat
skills but again she is your
garden-variety average person so the way
that Marvel has presented Peggy Carter
to us and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I think has been nothing short of
spectacular
and the reason why is because I think
there's this kind of belief that exists
out there then unless a female character
in Marvel Comics has superpowers that
she's of no real use to anyone aside
from being some kind of an emotional
support and we see this playing out with
various characters in Marvel Comics but
the way that we've seen her portray the
way that we've seen Peggy Carter
portrayed in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe really kind of defies this
logic and it presents to us this idea
that just because a woman has no
superpowers does not mean that she has
to be relegated to the point of being a
love interest with Peggy Carter despite
the fact that we saw her at the end of
Captain America the First Avenger and
then picked back up with her at with
Captain America the Winter Soldier we
don't know what really went on with her
life but we do know that she was a
founding member of shield and this
really kind of lends credence to the
fact that she is a very important
character in terms of the evolution of
intelligence gathering within the United
States and the world as a whole and it
makes her a very intelligent and
important person and this is what I
really like about this is what I really
enjoy about Marvel real
kind of including her character in
addition with regards to her having a TV
show this offers a lot more stretching
room and a lot more movement for Marvel
to really kind of expand on her
character more so than they could with a
film because of Marvel came along and
created a two hour or two and a half
hour film based on agent Carter they
would have to essentially cover
everything that went on with her life
between the time that Captain America
was presumed dead and the time that he
met back up with her again at the end of
the winter Winter Soldier over that
two-and-a-half hour time period and it
would be very constrained and it would
be very very rushed simply because of
the actions in the situations that she
got involved in in terms of being a
founding member of shield and so with
the TV show we're going to see a lot
more exposure we're going to see her
grow a lot more and I'm really hoping
that Marvel continues this trend of
keeping her as a character that goes
beyond simply being an individual a
woman who was in love with Steve Rogers
supposedly saw him die never got over it
then developed Alzheimer's and died
I'm really hoping they kind of expand on
it and make her a very pivotal character
and make her a very important character
and really add a lot of meat and
potatoes to what it is she has to offer
now in terms of Hayley Atwell actually
playing the role of Peggy Carter I think
she's done a fantastic job
now Marvel has made some changes here
and there they made her British fighting
alongside Americans as opposed to an
American fighting alongside the French
but Hayley Atwell is gorgeous and she is
beautiful and I don't care if she was
sitting in a room watching paint peel
for two and a half hours I would sit in
that theater and watch that movie to the
bitter end just because of the fact that
she is beautiful to look at so with her
kind of portraying this character and
really kind of acting this character in
such a way I think that she's done a
fantastic job by taking the element of
Peggy Carter and taking the role that
was given to her and really kind of
again elevating her to a more important
figure and elevating her beyond the
realm of simply being relegated to a
love interest of Steve Rogers with that
being said I'm going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and he'll catch you guys later